[Music]
once upon a time in Hollywood might turn
out to be a career landmark film from
one of the most exciting directors of
this generation here's everything you
need to know before you see Quentin
Tarantino's newest movie it's been
nearly four years since Tarantino's last
film the hateful eight and anticipation
has been building for his next flick
ever since things really started to heat
up in the summer of 2017 when The
Hollywood Reporter announced that
Tarantino's next project would be a film
set in Hollywood at the time of the
Manson murders the film secured
distribution from Sony in the fall of
2017 and by January of 2018 Leonardo
DiCaprio had signed on to work with
Tarantino again on the project the film
spent the first six months of 2018 FIFA
yup it's cast as it headed into
production when it came time for a
release date Sony initially aimed for
August ninth 2019 which would mark the
50th anniversary of Sharon Tate's murder
at the hands of the Manson Family by the
summer of 2018 that release date had
changed to July 26th with insiders
noting a release date in July would give
the film more time to play in front of
summer audiences as of early july 2019 a
large number of critics and fans have
yet to see the film but we do have its
initial reaction from the cannes film
festival to rely on in terms of its
quality after its world premiere Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood received a
six-minute standing ovation from the can
crowd and reviews coming out of the
festival have been largely positive
though the ending which Peter Bradshaw
from The Guardian called startling and
provocative proved divisive most critics
were pleased with Tarantino's visual
style the replication of 1960s Hollywood
and the chemistry between first-time
scene partners DiCaprio and Pitt so
while not everyone agrees
odds are this is a movie worth looking
forward to like inglourious basterds and
Django Unchained once upon a time in
Hollywood is set against a very
particular historical backdrop in both
of those films Tarantino took liberties
as he saw fit in an effort to best serve
his story blowing up a whole plantation
house full of slavers in Django and
flatout machine-gunning Hitler in the
face in Basterds with the press billing
the film as an alternate history fans
have developed a theory that Tarantino
will continue his tradition of toying
with our expectations about what really
happened in our own past the film is set
in 1969 Hollywood but Tarantino didn't
necessarily have to set his film in our
actual 1969 Hollywood
this is conceivably a world in which
Sharon Tate could survive the night she
was supposed to be murdered in which
Manson could get his comeuppance and in
which Hollywood could move forward into
some different version of the future
like many Tarantino films Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood quickly ignited a
degree of controversy after its premiere
at a press conference to promote the
film a New York Times journalist asked
Tarantino why Margot Robbie nominated
for an Oscar for her work in AI Tania
didn't get more dialogue in the film as
Sharon Tate the director was brief and
dismissive with his reply well I just
reject your hypotheses Robby then
stepped in to offer her own answer to
the question saying that she was able to
express numerous facets of Tate in a
nonverbal way to really show those
wonderful sides of her I think could be
adequately done without speaking she
added that it was interesting to be able
to explore the character even without
dialogue rarely do I get an opportunity
to spend so much time on my own as a
character going through a day-to-day
existence over his nearly three decades
of filmmaking Tarantino has developed a
kind of stock company of frequent
collaborators and many of them returned
to work with him again for Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood while Margot Robbie is
a first-timer both DiCaprio and Pitt
have worked with Tarantino before Pitt
in Inglourious Basterds and DiCaprio in
Django Unchained the film will mark Kurt
Russell's third time working with
Tarantino
Sterns ii michael Madsen's forth and
stunt woman and actress Zooey Belle's
six sadly one frequent Tarantino
collaborator apparently ended up on the
cutting room floor Tim Roth who has
appeared in three Tarantino features and
the anthology film four rooms was cast
in the film but did not appear in the
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood caught
Jonah can check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bells so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]